My dad wants nothing for Father's Day.
"Nothing at all?"
I asked.
"Not a thing,"...
...said Dad.
Last year, I gave him a funny tie.
It made everyone laugh.
Dad says he has enough ties.
Last year, my sister gave him a hat.
It made him look like a big rabbit.
Dad says he has enough hats.
Last year, my brother gave him socks.
Dad wore them once.
I think Dad has enough socks.
Last year, Mom gave him a computer game.
It made his computer crash.
Dad said,..
"Enough computer games!"
This year, Dad wants to watch TV.
He wants to take it easy and play.
He wants nothing, but we have a plan.
We will watch TV.
We will play.
And we will give him the biggest hug just for Father's Day.